sometimes no matter how great the rest
of the movie is
there's that one moment you just keep
coming back to
we're covering the biggest pause worthy
moments in 1990s filmmaking
the funny the sexy and the downright
embarrassing
the classic 1999 science fiction film
the matrix
tells the story of a group of people who
one day realize that the world they live
in
is a simulation which they then seek to
break free from
funny enough a similar thing happened to
a small percentage of viewers
during a certain scene in the film when
a small production error gave them an
unexpected reminder that the film they
were watching
was itself also a simulation
do you want to know what it
is the moment comes when two of our
heroes
morpheus and neo are going to visit the
sage-like figure
known as the oracle as they stand in the
hallway
outside the door to her apartment
there's a gorgeously composed insert
shot
of niu's hand reaching out to grab the
reflective metal doorknob
however in addition to reflecting neo
and morpheus the doorknob is also
reflecting the camera lens
it's the sort of thing that you probably
won't notice the first few times you
watch the film
but once you see it you can't unsee it
that being said
the production team appears to have come
up with a pretty ingenious solution to
hide as much of the camera as possible
they've covered it with a replica of
morpheus outfit complete with his tie
and they've placed the camera in such a
way that it somewhat blends into
morpheus torso just behind it
to be honest unlike some production
goofs we're genuinely impressed by this
bit of old-school movie-making ingenuity
when pulp fiction introduces us to the
two hitman characters
jules winfield and vincent vega they're
arriving at an apartment building to
retrieve a briefcase that's been stolen
by a small time criminal named brett
and also to execute brett and his
friends
however before they can finish this job
an unseen attacker emerges from the
bathroom
brandishing a pistol he opens fire on
the two hit men
but once he finishes we see that somehow
he hit nothing but air
there are bullet holes in the wall
behind them but they themselves are
totally unharmed it's such an unlikely
outcome
that jules eventually comes to believe
that this event was a miracle
their lives were spared by god to give
them the chance to repent for
all the evil they've done this was
divine intervention
you know what divine intervention is
however some eagle-eyed audience members
noticed a small problem in the scene
if you pause the film during an earlier
shot in the apartment before the hidden
gunman appears
you'll see that the bullet holes are
already present in the wall behind jules
and vincent
now clearly this is just a production
error but if you want to go really far
down the rabbit hole of weird head
cannons
there's also an alternate explanation
what if there just happened to be some
bullet holes in that wall already
what if there was no miracle at all and
the real reason why jules and vincent
weren't harmed by the gunman's shots
was because he accidentally loaded up
his gun with blanks
the 1999 film fight club is one of the
most meticulously constructed movies of
all
time and more so than any other film
we're discussing today
you'll definitely need to pause the
movie if you want to catch some of this
film's hidden easter eggs
because some of them appear in only a
single frame each
we all remember tyler durden's first
iconic scene in the film
right while on a plane flight home from
a business trip our unnamed protagonist
suddenly realizes that there's a strange
man in red sunglasses seated next to him
played to perfection by brad pitt the
stranger then strikes up a conversation
and the two discuss airplane safety
cards homemade napalm
and soap although our narrator doesn't
realize it yet
this encounter is about to change the
direction of his life forever
but what if we told you that this
fateful meeting isn't actually durden's
first appearance in fight club
at several points earlier in the film
tyler briefly appears spliced into the
film for only a single frame in each
appearance
as though he's flickering in and out of
existence those of you who've already
seen the movie can probably guess why
the filmmakers decided to do this
and for those of you who haven't we
wouldn't want to spoil any of this
movie's many delightful twists
so you'll have to check it out for
yourselves the star wars films have
always presented landscapes that are
rich with surprising visual details
and secret easter eggs one of the most
famous hidden examples occurs in the
1999 film star wars episode 1 the
phantom menace
but it comes and goes so quickly that
you'll probably have to pause the film
to see it for yourself
the moment occurs midway through the
movie when the galactic senate is
meeting on coruscant
among the many aliens that we see
gathered together in this meeting
are a trio of creatures that will
definitely be familiar to most film fans
they appear to be the same species as
the aliens from the 1982 movie
e.t the extraterrestrial this inclusion
makes sense
once you remember that the creator of
star wars george lucas
and the creator of et steven spielberg
our long time friends and collaborators
in fact this is the second crossover
we've seen between these two franchises
since e.t the extraterrestrial also had
a star wars reference in it
when e.t is wandering around on
halloween he sees a child in a yoda
costume
e.t then starts to approach the child
repeating the word home
over and over again before his human
companions drag him away
the 1997 film men in black tells the
story of a secret organization
that protects the earth from
extraterrestrial threats and works to
keep the existence of aliens a secret
shortly after our protagonist jay is
recruited into this organization
he's given a tour of the men in black's
extensive underground base
though there are many unforgettable
sights he encounters during this
sequence
one shot is so dense with information
that audiences had no choice but to
pause the scene if they wanted to take
it all in
jay comes across a computer terminal
that sits at the base of a massive array
of holographic screens
all displaying real-time footage of
various real-world celebrities who are
secretly aliens
among the many celebrities displayed on
the screen are danny devito
hal roker sylvester stallone dion
warwick
newt gingrich george lucas and even some
men in black filmmakers
including director barry sonnenfeld and
executive producer steven spielberg
now we've arrived at what's probably the
most hotly debated
and controversial moment we're covering
today a certain
infamous hidden message that appears in
the sky in the lion king
the moment comes midway through the film
when simba stands contemplatively
at the edge of a cliff overwhelmed by
the weight of his past regrets
he collapses into a tired heat as he
does so his weight sent a cloud of dust
and leaves
swirling up into the air for a few
frames the dust appears to arrange
itself into three letters
interpreted by some viewers as s s-e-x
christian groups raised concerns about
the moment though disney denied they
were actually seeing anything
later interviews with animators revealed
that the message was supposed to say
sfx a nod to the film's special effects
department
however for the 2002 imax re-release
and in all subsequent editions of the
film disney decided to save itself any
more future headaches by just removing
the letters entirely
replacing them with abstract swirls the
1999
film cruel intentions contains no
shortage of sexy pause-worthy moments
but there's one scene in particular
that's gone down in cinema history
as one of the steamiest images ever
captured on celluloid
when the rich and heartless catherine
discovers that court her former lover
has left her for a girl named cecile she
comes up with a plan for revenge
catherine befriends cecile without
court's knowledge and makes it her
mission to corrupt cecile in his eyes by
making her sleep with as many
other people as possible one day when
the two girls are having a picnic in the
park
cecile expresses some hesitance about
her new boyfriend saying that she's
never even kissed a boy before
catherine seeing an opportunity to help
push the seal towards promiscuity
offers to show her the ropes by
practicing with her cecile follows
catherine's lead
and after a brief yet passionate makeout
catherine pulls away
leaving cecile clearly wanting more it
seems as though audiences were also left
wanting more and
this iconic kiss became a moment that
many were fond of pausing
and or re-watching over and over again
it won an mtv movie award for best kiss
and has since been parodied many times
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you